a bill in Montana would ban the teaching
of a number of scientific theories
including gravity cell theory and
evolution in the public school
curriculum more than 20 people have
testified against this bill this is
Senate Bill 235 in Montana what the
legislature wants to do is regulate the
science curriculum and actually prevent
the teaching of the established and
accepted scientific theories they claim
they want to prevent kids from being
taught things that are untrue but what
it would actually allow them to do is
prevent teaching of what are the
accepted scientific theories now
remember
in science theory has a different
meaning than colloquially if I come to
you and I say I have a theory that short
people prefer the color yellow right
okay it's a hypothesis it's not really a
theory because in science theory means
the best explanation we have of the
facts